Russia has been banned from the Winter
Olympics yeah but don't feel bad Russia
even though you won't win any gold
medals you did win the US presidential
election more evidence coming out
against Roy Moore more like more
evidence again yeah
there was no pun there on more it just
happened that way that's one of the
beautiful things about comedy anyway
yesterday another woman came forward
with proof from the 1980s that Roy Moore
pursued her when she was seventeen
seventeen yeah Moore said what can I say
back then I was into older women so uh
his yeah a spokeswoman for Roy Moore has
defended him saying there are plenty of
women in Alabama that he didn't sexually
abuse that's a true statement yeah
plenty of women he didn't yeah sexual
abuse he said we prefer to look at the
glass as half and roped which I thought
was interesting seriously that's like
saying look how many people Jeffrey
Dahmer didn't eat give the guy a break
give them a break a new report says that
Mike Pence's wife thinks that Donald
Trump is totally vile yeah quinces
intently Donald Trump's wife thinks
Donald Trump
[Applause]
it's like the way he peers out he's
always peering out angrily he's like an
old mountain lion waiting to pounce on
something on a trail he's waiting
outside old mountain lying waiting for
someone to make a person into a burger
yeah exactly and then he can eat it yeah
yeah speaking of Mike Pence has been
reported that when Mike Pence was in
college this is so perfect when Mike
Pence was in college he ratted on his
fraternity for having a keg yes pence
told his fraternity brothers beer the
next thing you know you'll be inviting
women over clothes we're smelling salts
to revive him now yeah that was not
cocaine just want to be clear about that
he's we're gonna need texts the this is
where the state of Montana is suing the
maker of oxycontin over the opioid
epidemic yes in a related story the
state of Wisconsin announced it is suing
food
because they tend to be heavy enough
people that's kind of this woman sitting
in the front right here just leaned
forward and looked over at the card like
is there more to that joke right here
she totally did show me what you did you
went huh and he looked over like there's
gonna be more on that I know there does
I said it down Billy she's like huh oh
he gets paid Pizza Hut that's right I
said Pizza Hut is planning to start
adding alcohol to their deliveries yeah
yeah well this of course raises the
question which wine pairs best with
terrible pizza
chef's tell me they don't sponsor
they're not a sponsor on the show are
they sometimes why don't we talk about
these things before the show you just
sitting back there I think they know
they have terrible yeah I know it's just
at a reasonable price right right yeah
they're like for what you just paid
that's it's kind of pizza well it's it's
in a hut yeah it's in the hut yeah yeah
yeah
who goes to a hut for good pizza yeah
what do you want you know what I love
whatever problem we were in before with
Pizza Hut it just got a low we just
talked about it for a long time and I
think I came up with their new slogan
it's pretty good if for all we spent for
the people we spent that much money and
it's from a hut a man in Florida is in
trouble for exposing his penis to his
uber driver yeah
driver said that's not what I meant when
I asked for tip now folks
you